award season has officially begun and
the stars are already slaying the red
carpet what a way to start off 2018 and
very glamorous style
[Music]
on Tuesday some of Hollywood's biggest
names hit up the 29th annual Palm
Springs International Film Festival
awards gala in Palm Springs California
and the fashion was on point Salma Hayek
and Saoirse Ronan both wowed in Gucci I
have a really really brilliant stylist
Armie Hammer opted for a gold Dolce &
Gabbana tux jacket and Christian
Louboutin shoes but admitted the
ensemble wasn't his first choice I
almost wore the same jacket the same
Rockville's way yeah yeah yeah Jessica
Chastain and Octavia Spencer both
stunned in black
Wow gal gadot looked picture-perfect in
this sexy yellow number Holly Hunter was
white-hot and Allison Janney who rocked
this off-the-shoulder emerald gown
admitted walking in her heels wasn't all
that easy rode in my heels mary j blige
rocked this baby blue Elie Saab gown and
revealed to ET how she's prepping for
the Golden Globes on Sunday I'm dieting
I'm just you know just kind of relaxing
and just enjoying a moment of just being
nominated that's the beautiful thing in
this soul
you